ZDF heute live schön dass ihr dabei seid
herzlich willkommen
David gegen Goliath vor dem Europäischen
Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte sechs
Kinder und Jugendliche zwischen 11 und
24 Jahre alt Klagen gegen 32 Staaten
darunter ist auch Deutschland sie wollen
die Regierungen dazu bringen mehr für
den Klimaschutz zu tun
klimakräger versus Europa darüber wollen
wir heute reden und deshalb freuen wir
uns wenn ihr dabei seid schickt uns eure
Fragen und Kommentare einfach posten
oder ihr könnt uns natürlich auch gerne
eine E-Mail schicken wir sprechen gleich
mit dem Klima Forscher motivativ und mit
unserem Rechtsexperten Jan Henrich jetzt
schalten aber erstmal nach Straßburg vor
dem Europäischen Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte steht mein Kollege
Natalie Niedermeier hallo Nathan
guten Abend
na dann lass uns kurz gemeinsam
anschauen worum es denn da genau geht
Christian Semm hat das für uns
zusammengefasst
andre Katharina Martin Mariana Claudia
und Sophia sind aus Portugal nach
Straßburg gekommen damit sich in Sachen
Klimaschutz etwas ändert die Länder die
sie verklagt haben tun zu wenig für den
Klimaschutz finden die Jugendlichen sie
sehen ihre Grundrechte verletzt
sehr wichtig dass diese und andere
Generationen verstehen dass wir das
nicht nur für uns selbst machen sondern
für uns alle unsere Stimme ist gemeinsam
viel stärker
2017 Hitzewelle auf der iberischen
Halbinsel Temperaturen teilweise über 40
Grad dazu trockene Winde die
waldbrandserie in dem Jahr besonders
verheerend vor allem diese Feuer seien
für die sechs Jugendlichen der Auslöser
gewesen aktiv zu werden sagen sie der
Klimawandel beeinträchtigt unseren
Alltag erzählt der 15-Jährige Andreas
ich möchte zum Beispiel in meinem Zimmer
sein und lernen oder schlafen aber es
ist so heiß dass das schwierig ist ich
möchte nach draußen gehen und nicht dort
bewegen können Fahrrad fahren oder
Basketball spielen aber es ist so heiß
dass ich es einfach nicht kann
aussagen wie diese sind wichtig denn die
Jugendlichen müssen die Richter in
Straßburg davon überzeugen dass sie
persönlich von den Folgen des
Klimawandels betroffen sind die
Angeklagten Länder vertreten von über 80
Anwälten weisen die Anklage zurück sie
basiere auf bloßen Annahmen und leeren
Hypothesen hieß es ein Urteil wird im
nächsten Jahr erwartet gewinnen die
Jugendlichen könnten den 32 Ländern hohe
Strafen drohen
Nathan jetzt verklagt man als Elfjährige
nicht unbedingt gerade mal so 32 starten
wer steht hinter den am Kindern und
Jugendlichen
ja also sie sind heute morgen hier schon
mit ihren Familien gemeinsam angereist
die hier auch der Anhörung beigewohnt
haben und eine ganze Reihe an
Institutionen und Organisationen und
Personen unterstützen Sie hier natürlich
auch ein Team aus verschiedenen
Anwältinnen und Anwälten koordiniert von
dem global climate Lidl Action Network
dass ich auf solche Klagen spezialisiert
hat und was auch sehr interessant ist
dass auch die Kommissarin für
Menschenrechte des Europarats hier heute
Ihnen hier bei der Klage den Rücken
gestärkt hat sie hat gesagt das ist eine
historische Chance hier für das Gericht
für Millionen Kinder und Jugendliche
eine gesunde Zukunft zu sichern ganz
anders als zum Beispiel die
EU-Kommission die sich auch eingebracht
hat in das Verfahren mit einem Statement
heute und die sich dort auf die Seite
der Mitgliedstaaten schlägt und sagt mit
ihrer derzeitigen Klimapolitik und dem
unterzeichnen und ratifizieren des
Pariser Klimaabkommens würden sie hier
schon ausreichend Klimapolitik machen
also es gibt eine ganze Reihe an
unterstütz aber natürlich auch Gegenwind
und wenn ich hier in den Chat schaue
dann kommt auch Unterstützung aus dem
Chat da schreibt Uli auf Youtube gut
dass sie klagen alles geht viel zu
langsam oder gen schreibt auf Youtube
ich bin 23 und eure Klimapolitik macht
alle Jobs kaputt ich kenne sehr viele
ich habe sehr viele Freunde in meinem
Alter die auch so denken Nathan du hast
den ersten Tag heute verfolgt was ist da
heute passiert
ja direkt hinter mir sind wie eben schon
erzählt habe heute morgen um 7 Uhr also
die sechs Klägerinnen und Kläger
gemeinsam mit den Anwältinnen und
Anwälten die sie vertreten und ihren
Familien eingetroffen da haben sie
verschiedene Unterstützerinnen und
Unterstützer hier in Empfang genommen
mit Transparenten und Sprüchen und
Plakaten und dann sind sie eben hier
rein in das Gericht und dann äh ja in
diesem Gerichtssaal gab es dann eine
erste Anhörung man muss sich das mal
vorstellen das sind schon enorme
Dimensionen als erstes haben dann die 22
Richterinnen und Richter den Saal
betreten bevor es dann tatsächlich
losging ähm wir haben es gerade im
Beitrag schon gehört ich habe heute
gehört 87 Anwältin und Anwälte der
Angeklagten starten die hier vertreten
waren also es ist schon ein enorm großer
Prozess mit sehr vielen Beteiligten und
die alle haben also dann diese erste
Anhörung gehört bei der also die
zunächst die Angeklagten Staaten
abgegeben haben dann die zwei
Rechtsanwältin in Vertretung für die
Klägerinnen und Kläger und dann eben die
gerade angesprochene Kommissarin für
Menschenrechte des Europarats und die
EU-Kommission und weitere und dann gab
es zunächst eine Pause mittags und dann
noch eine zweite
anhörungsrunde in der vor allem dann
Fragen des Gerichts an die verschiedenen
Verfahrensbeteiligten geklärt wurden und
dann gab es noch mal etwas ein Hin und
Her zwischen diesen Fragen und Antworten
und dann im Anschluss genau verschiedene
Statements noch von den Klägerinnen und
Klägern und ja auch wirklich einen
enormes Presse aufgebaut ein sehr großes
Interesse an diesem Prozess was man dann
auch im Nachgang an den Prozess hier
noch erlebt hat nach der zweiten
anhörungsphase die klagerechtet sicher
auch gegen Deutschland wir haben das
eingangs gesagt haben sie hat sich
Deutschland da jetzt positioniert
also Deutschland als einzelner Staat hat
sich jetzt heute nicht in der
Verhandlung positioniert weil es sind ja
eben ganze 32 Staaten jetzt angeklagt
und die haben sich auf Bitten des
Gerichts zusammengetan und haben eine
gemeinsame Erklärung hier abgegeben vor
dem Gericht mit Ausnahme einzelner
Staaten wie zum Beispiel Portugal die
natürlich in der Klage noch mal anders
betroffen sind weil eben die Klägerinnen
und Kläger aus Portugal kommen aber
dieses gemeinsame Statement der Staaten
also damit eben auch Deutschland
positioniert sich ganz klar und sagt
diese Klage sollte eben abgewiesen
werden sie führen da zum Beispiel oder
primär auch formalistische Gründe an
etwa dass sie sagen die einzelnen
Staaten wie zum Beispiel Deutschland
würde gar keine Zuständigkeit in diesem
Fall treffen und sie sagen auch
eigentlich hätten die Klägerinnen und
Kläger zunächst die nationalen Gerichte
also etwa auch in Deutschland ein
Gericht anhören müssen das sehen die
Klägerinnen und Klägern nicht so und zum
Beispiel eben auch die Kommissarin für
Menschenrechte auch nicht aber insofern
ist das im Grunde diese gemeinsame
Position zu der Deutschland auch gehört
und Deutschland hat eben im Vorfeld auch
jedenfalls nach Unterlagen die ich
einsehen durfte und vorliegen habe
versucht gemeinsam eben auch mit den
anderen Staaten dieses Verfahren in die
Länge zu ziehen das Gericht hatte sich
entschieden die Klage als beschleunigtes
Verfahren durchzuführen und da hatten
eben Deutschland auch andere Staaten die
anderen Staaten dann
interveniert und vorgeschlagen dass doch
eben nicht zu tun und Deutschland
ansonsten wie eben auch die anderen
Staaten argumentiert dass seine
Klimapolitik zunächst einmal nicht die
Möglichkeit hat Einfluss zu nehmen auf
die Lebensbedingungen in Portugal
insofern ja hat sich Deutschland hier
gemeinsam eben mit den anderen Staaten
schon klar positioniert Nathan ganz
lieben Dank für deine Informationen live
aus Straßburg mach's gut tschüss
ja das Kinder und Jugendliche Staaten
verklagen weil sie nicht genug gegen den
Klimaschutz tun ist neu aber gibt es
eben juristisch da auch eine Aussicht
auf Erfolg das wollen wir jetzt
besprechen mit unserem Rechtsexperten
Jan Henrich hallo Jan schönes Event bist
Jan die Frage gibt es direkt hier aus
dem Chat welche Erfolgschancen kann so
ein Prozess haben lass uns noch mal
aufdröseln verhandelt wird ja vor dem
Europäischen Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte sind die Kläger und
Klägerinnen da überhaupt an der
richtigen Stelle die sechs jungen
Menschen aus Portugal machen ja gerade
geltend unmittelbar selbst betroffen zu
sein von den Auswirkungen des
Klimawandels in ihrer Gesundheit in
ihrem Alltag in ihrer Lebensgestaltung
und sie sagen eben dadurch sind sie in
über ihren Grundrechten verletzt und
deswegen haben sie sich an das Gericht
in Straßburg gewendet und das Gericht
nimmt diese Klage zumindest mal ernst
das sieht man da durch wie verhandelt
wurde wie auch terminiert wurde wir
haben gerade eben schon gehört das
Gericht hat
dem dem Verfahren ein beschleunigten
Status zugewiesen und es hat auch sehr
umfangreich Stellungnahmen eingeholt
heute sehr umfangreich verhandelt
normalerweise sind Verhandlung von dem
igma etwas kürzer das heißt zumindest an
der falschen Stelle sind sie dann nicht
Nathan hat es ja eben schon erzählt
diese Klage sorgt für wahnsinnig viel
mediale Aufmerksamkeit aber kommen wir
eben auf diese Frage zurück die auch
eben im Chat gestellt wurde hat sie
dennoch Chancen auf Erfolg das ist
tatsächlich noch mal eine andere Sache
in diesem Fall gibt es sehr viele Hürden
auch sehr viele juristische Hürden die
geklärt werden offene Fragen die geklärt
werden müssen und
das Gericht muss zunächst mal
entscheiden ob in diese Klage überhaupt
zulässig ist es so normalerweise werden
wird der der Europäische Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte in Straßburg erst
angerufen wenn der Rechtsweg erschöpft
ist das heißt wenn man keinen Erfolg vor
nationalen Gerichten hatte das ist nicht
passiert die die sechs jungen Menschen
aus Portugal haben sich direkt nach
Straßburg gewendet und es ist auch
ungewöhnlich dass so viele Staaten auf
einmal angeklagt sind und daneben
natürlich noch die große Frage ob der
Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte überhaupt
die Einhaltung der Klimaschutz Ziel der
Pariser Klimaschutzziele überprüfen kann
und wenn ja wie also da ist noch einiges
zu klären aber jetzt nehmen wir mal an
die Klägerinnen bekommen recht was
müssten die Staaten dann tun oder hier
gibt es auch direkt die Frage von Ulli
aber zu einer konkreten Handlung kann
man die Regierung nicht zwingen fragt er
oder das ist zumindest unwahrscheinlich
normalerweise läuft es so ab dass der
Europäische Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte ein Urteil spricht das
auch bindend ist für die Mitgliedstaaten
aber in dem Urteil in erster Linie
feststellt ob eine Rechtsverletzung
vorliegt und gegebenenfalls auch eine
Entschädigung zu sprechen kann
wie mit dieser recht Verletzung
umgegangen wird wie das Ganze dann
gelöst wird ob die dann aber eigentlich
in erster Linie den Mitgliedstaaten
selbst also ob eine konkrete Handlung
angeordnet werden kann ist offen da
gibt's auch Diskussion darüber was ist
unwahrscheinlich
es geht ja auch um nicht EU-Staaten wie
Russland Türkei Norwegen inwiefern
würdet ihr das überhaupt tangieren das
tangiert die genauso wie alle
Mitgliedstaaten wie alle hier
Angeklagten Staaten
man muss unterscheiden das ist der
Europäische Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte in Straßburg der ist
angegliedert an den Europarat und die
Europäische Menschenrechtskonvention da
sind sehr viele Mitglieder drin über 40
Mitglieder die dort angesprochen werden
können das ist was anderes als der
europäische Gerichtshof in Luxemburg der
ist für die Auslegung für EU Recht
zuständig das heißt das Urteil gilt
erstmal genauso für die nicht die
EU-Länder wie für die EU-Länder wobei
man hier sagen muss russland hatte sich
ja schon verabschiedet aus dem Europarat
also Russland die auch noch in der Klage
mit aufgetaucht sind die wird das dann
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr treffen also
nicht ganz trivial aber dafür bist du ja
da es gibt noch eine Frage wer bekommt
denn das Geld wenn die Staaten Bezahlung
verurteilt werden auch das noch eine
offene Frage normalerweise bei
Menschenrechtsverletzungen wenn die
festgestellt werden und eine
Entschädigung dann zugesprochen wird
dann kommt die an die Kläger selbst aber
hier in diesem Fall könnte das ein
bisschen schwierig sein weil natürlich
für Klimaschutz an sich und nicht für
individuelle Maßnahmen geklagt wird das
heißt da halt ist persönlich für
unwahrscheinlich dass da wirklich die
Kläger selbst Geld bekommen könnten aber
das ist natürlich alles noch offen es
gibt ja immer mehr klagen für mehr
Klimaschutz ist das vielleicht auch ein
Stück weit die Verzweiflung der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dass sie
irgendwie finden der Staat macht aus
ihrer Sicht nicht genug um eben das
Klima zu retten ja die Zahl der
klimaklagen hat tatsächlich im
zugenommen und diese Klagen sind ja auch
teilweise sehr erfolgreich also 2021
noch gar nicht so lange her da hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht ein
wegweisendes Urteil gesprochen auf die
Klage hin bzw auf die
Verfassungsbeschwerde von
klimaaktivisten in Deutschland und hat
dort eben entschieden dass das damalige
Klimaschutzgesetz verfassungswidrig ist
und überarbeitet werden muss und
verschärft werden muss also Erfolge gibt
es dadurch aus nicht nur gegen Staaten
übrigens auch zum Beispiel der Ölkonzern
Shell wurde in den Niederlanden verklagt
und wurde auch da wurde er verurteilt
seine CO2-Emissionen einzudämmen das
heißt diese klimaklagen die Stellen
tatsächlich einen immer größeres
Werkzeug für klimaaktivistinnen und
klimaaktivisten da um eben ihre Ziele
durchzusetzen vielen Dank lieber Jan für
deine Informationen dass Sie uns hier im
Studio besucht hast danke gut tschüss
ja welche Bedeutung hat diese Klage wie
wichtig ist sie nach der Hitzewelle
unter anderem in Italien Spanien oder
den Unwetterkatastrophen in Griechenland
und Libyen dieses Jahr darüber möchte
ich jetzt mit dem Klimaforscher
motivativ sprechen
guten Abend relativ schön dass die Zeit
für uns haben genau relativ ist das
nicht ein gewisser Weise beschämend für
unsere Gesellschaft das jetzt Kinder und
Jugendliche vor Gericht ziehen müssen
damit mehr für den Klimaschutz passiert
absolut das ist wirklich etwas was man
eigentlich gar nicht fassen kann die
jungen Menschen müssen versuchen ihre
Zukunft zu sichern müssen vor Gericht
ziehen um ihr Recht zu bekommen und
insofern denke ich ist es völlig
gerechtfertigt dass sie jungen Menschen
jetzt immer öfter Gerichte anrufen und
meiner Meinung nach ist das auch eine
der großen Hebel die uns überhaupt noch
verbleiben um tatsächlich die Politik
aber auch die Wirtschaft dazu zu bewegen
endlich mal etwas für den Klimaschutz zu
tun ein Abkommen zu unterzeichnen wie
das Pariser komm ist sie eine Sache aber
sich daran zu halten ist die andere
Sache und die allermeisten Länder
eigentlich alle Länder halten sich nicht
daran was sie in Paris versprochen haben
die Anwältinnen und Anwälte der
Regierung haben heute davon gesprochen
dass das da bloße Annahmen werden zum
Teil oder leere Hypothesen auf denen die
Klagen basierend auf denen die Klage
basieren würde oder Griechenland sagt
das der Klimawandel sich wohl nicht
direkt auf das Leben oder die Gesundheit
der Menschen auszuwirken scheint erleben
wir diese Auswirkungen nicht
mittlerweile sehr sehr deutlich kann das
die Verteidigungsstrategie der Staaten
sein nein also
außer Wissenschaft her kann man das
nicht ableiten ich möchte die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation zitieren die
vor der Weltklimakonferenz in Glasgow
also der vorletzten Weltklimakonferenz
noch mal deutlich gemacht hat in einem
offenen Brief dass der Klimawandel die
größte Gesundheitsbedrohung für die
Menschheit ist und ich möchte auch daran
erinnern dass jedes Jahr auch bei uns in
Deutschland
tausende von Menschen sterben an der
Hitze das heißt also man kann hier nicht
sagen dass die Menschen nicht direkt
betroffen sind es ist ja nicht nur die
Hitze sind ja auch Überschwemmung
Überflutung wir sehen ja ganz ganz viele
Tote auch dadurch und insofern ist das
eine unhaltbare Argumentation die
Politik ja aufbaut
Brown leaf Paddel schreibt dazu auf
Youtube wenn sich die Staaten dagegen
wehren geben Sie damit indirekt zu dass
sie sich nicht um die Klimakrise kümmern
ja das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen ich
denke sie fürchten einfach dass sie
schärfere Maßnahmen ergreifen müssen
oder überhaupt erst einmal
ambitionierte Maßnahmen ergreifen müssen
und wir haben ja jetzt bei uns gesehen
als das beispielsweise um das Tempolimit
gehen als es um das heizungsgesetz Gehen
das doch offensichtlich
ein großer Widerstand auch in der
Bevölkerung existiert und die Politik
sind nicht traut dann gegen die
Bevölkerung bestimmte Dinge auch
durchzusetzen aber das hat eben auch
damit zu tun dass die Politik immer
vergisst die Anreize gleich mit zu
beschließen es wird schon so lange
darüber geredet ein Klima Geld
einzuführen da steht auch im
Koalitionsvertrag aber es ist nicht
geschehen das heißt die Menschen werden
belastet aber sie werden nicht entlastet
und das ist meiner Meinung nach eben der
große wegfehler zumindest an der
deutschen Politik
bleiben wir doch kurz dabei wenn wir uns
den Streit jetzt zum Beispiel über die
Wärmepumpen anschauen oder auch diese
gerade beschlossenen Maßnahmen gegen
Wohnungsnot wo ja der
energiesparstandard eher 40 eher zuerst
mal ausgesetzt wurde es ist dann viel
mehr so dass Klimaschutzmaßnahmen dann
im Zweifel hinten angestellt werden also
dass dieser Schuss noch nicht gehört
wurde das beobachte ich seit Jahrzehnten
es ist immer scheinbar etwas anderes
wichtiger als der Klimaschutz denken wir
an den Film des früheren amerikanischen
Vizepräsidenten el go der hat ja 2007
den Film eine unbequeme Wahrheit
gemacht und hat dann später auch den
Friedensnobelpreis bekommen zusammen mit
dem weltklimaat also mit der
Klimawissenschaft und dann dachte ich
tatsächlich okay das war's und jetzt
werden die
Länder wirklich
werden und was ist dann passiert dann
kamen die Finanzkrise und schon war das
Thema wieder weg und sehr sehr lange
dann kam Fridays for future kam das
Thema wieder hoch und dann kam Corona
aber das Thema wieder weg und so geht es
immer weiter und jetzt haben wir die
Inflation und die Energiekrise und dann
spielt Klimaschutz wieder keine rolle
ich denke die Verantwortlichen spüren
überhaupt nicht dass das alles
miteinander zusammenhängt und das
Klimaschutz letzten Endes unseren
Wohlstand sichert und wenn man kein
Klimaschutz betreiben dass wir immer
mehr in die Krise kommen auch ökonomisch
und deswegen bin ich der Meinung sollte
man jetzt auch das nicht immer auf den
Klimaschutz fokussieren sondern man
sollte vielleicht sagen es geht hier um
Zukunftsfähigkeit ob wir wirklich in den
nächsten Jahrzehnten noch günstige
Lebensbedingungen auf der Erde haben und
vor allen Dingen auch ob diejenigen die
kein Thema Schutz betreiben dann nicht
doch hinten runterfallen ökonomisch
gesehen wir sind ja gerade bei der
Elektromobilität in Deutschland auch
Hersteller sind enorm unter Druck weil
sie lange geschlafen haben weil sie
einfach sich nicht umstellen wollten und
das kann sich eben rechnen wenn ich bei
dem neuen Technologien vorne auf der
Lokomotive sitzt der wird irgendwann das
Nachsehen haben
ich würde noch gerne noch mal kurz nach
Straßburg schauen am zu der Klage da
gibt es wahrscheinlich wenn überhaupt
Teil also
nichts Verfahren brauchen ihre Zeit
dauern lange kommen solche
Entscheidungen dann vielleicht auch
einfach sehr sehr spät
ja wir hätten ja viel früher anfangen
müssen ich möchte es mal an einen
klassischen Beispiel deutlich machen
dass eben auch zeigt dass er ökonomisch
wichtig ist dass wir Klimaschutz
betreiben vor genau 50 Jahren also 1973
hat mir die erste Ölkrise die jungen
Menschen werden sich dann nicht erinnern
weil sie noch gar nicht geboren waren
und damals gab es eine Tempolimit damals
gab es sonntags war Verbote spätestens
seit nur noch werden müssen dass die
Energieversorgung über die fossilen
Brennstoffe offensichtlich keine Zukunft
hat und wir haben daraus nicht gelernt
wir sind immer weiter in die
fossilienbranche auch egal also in Kohle
Öl und er das andere Länder haben es
besser gemacht wir gehen immer die haben
damals eben Begriffen okay unsere
Energieversorgung steht auf Töne sind
Füßen und die haben jetzt diese Probleme
nicht die auch mit der Wärmepumpe z.B
früh viel früher angefangen und es recht
sich jetzt ist dass wir in Deutschland
immer so langsam sind und vor allen
Dingen auch dass wir ein Volk von
Bedenkenträgern sind egal was man machen
will es gibt dann immer eine Initiative
die dagegen ist und irgendwie blockieren
wir uns alle gegenseitig und es gibt
nichts voran nicht nur beim Klima
sondern in vielen anderen Bereichen auch
wir werden immer mehr Bereichen
abgehängt jetzt gibt es ja Menschen
junge Menschen die kleben für mehr
Klimaschutz so wie es die selbst
ernannte letzte Generation macht oder
besser klagen was glauben Sie mit
welchen Maßnahmen es am Ende dann doch
mehr zu erreichen
ich denke das klagen
würde ich favorisieren jedenfalls denn
das ist ja möglich im Rahmen der Gesetze
und ich bin der Meinung niemand steht
über dem Gesetz deswegen finde ich
sollte man in einem Rechtsstaat auch
keine Gesetze brechen außerdem muss ich
sagen dass bei der letzten Generation
doch zwei sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit
generiert wird aber ich finde dass das
Ganze kontraproduktiv ist weil dann
bringt sehr viele Menschen gegen sich
auf das ist zum Beispiel bei den
klimaklagen nicht der Fall und es wird
eigentlich nur noch über die Form des
Protestes diskutiert und nicht mehr über
die Sache an sich also wie kommen der
wirklich beim Thema schon weiter wer
erreichen sie heute Abend in Hamburg und
da fand findet aktuell auch im
wetterkongress statt da hieß es heute
die Erde steht vor nicht mehr
abwendbaren massiven Veränderungen wie
sehen Sie das ähm sie sagen ja dieser
Point of no Return während noch nicht
erreicht
meine Frage der Interpretation im
Prinzip ist dass sie jetzt schon nach
zwölf ich weiß ja nicht wie viel nach 12
aber ich habe vorhin schon gesagt der
sterben tausende von Menschen auch bei
uns in Deutschland infolge der globalen
Erwärmung wir sehen die Zunahme der
extremen Wetter Ereignisse unsere
Infrastruktur ist überhaupt nicht
angepasst auf dieses neue Klima und
niemand weiß ob es dann wirklich
irgendwann so ein Point of no Return
gibt dass sie Dinge sich dann für
selbständigen und dann nicht mehr zu
begrenzen sind persönlich glaube ich
nicht also die Erde hat doch sehr sehr
große Veränderung doch irgendwie
überlegt natürlich mit großen
Konsequenzen aber die Erde wird
natürlich bleiben das Leben wird bleiben
und ich bin jemand der eigentlich immer
versucht Mut zu machen es ist doch
wichtig dass wir wirklich nicht jetzt in
Fatalismus verfallen dass wenn ich sagen
ist und so alles zu spät es nutzt nichts
mehr ich finde man sollte versuchen
etwas etwas zu tun jeder und jede für
sich egal ob das nun weltweit was bringt
oder nicht aber ich glaube viele kleine
Maßnahmen anderen Ende doch ein Effekt
und dieser eine große Maßnahme um das
Thema zu retten gibt es ohnehin nicht
Jörg fragt auf Youtube
sie würden immer von wir sprechen er
sagt Kinder und Indien sind ganz andere
Märkte ich glaube die Frage der
Kommentar zählt in die Richtung was
bringt das wenn wir viele viele
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen auf den Weg bringen
aber China oder Indien eben
vergleichsweise wenig tun
ja also wenn man jetzt nackten Zahlen
betrachtet kann man so argumentieren
also wie in Deutschland haben ja einen
Anteil eine weltweiten CO2-Emissionen
von knapp zwei Prozent China von knapp
30 Prozent ja also und wir sitzen ja
buchstäblich alle im selben Boot das
heißt also wir haben sie mit einem
globalen Problem zu tun der Ort des
Ausstoßes und CO2 ist irrelevant weil
das so lange in der Atmosphäre verweilt
für Jahrhunderte für Jahrtausende und
deswegen verteilt er sich um den Erdball
und ist auch der Grund warum die Kohle
schmelzen obwohl da überhaupt kein CO2
ausgestoßen wird aber es gibt gute
Gründe warum Deutschland etwas tun
sollen auf der einen Seite hat
Deutschland schon die Möglichkeit auch
global etwas zu erreichen und hat er
schon getan mit dem erneuerbaren
Energien gesetzt 2000 Deutschland hat
fast immer Eingang der erneuerbaren
Energien bezahlbar gemacht und nur
deswegen BU wenn sie überall in der Welt
und wenn wir 20 50 20 60 zurückblicken
und wir haben es tatsächlich geschafft
globale Erwärmung zu begrenzen dann wird
man sagen okay ein wichtiges Element war
eben Deutschland dieser erneuerbare
Energien Gesetz das heißt also ein
kleines Land kann durch etwas durchaus
etwas für den Globus tun das ist eine
aber dann gibt es eben auch die Frage
der Gerechtigkeit auf der einen Seite
stoßen wir ja schon sehr sehr lange CO2
aus alles was unsere Eltern unsere große
in die Luft geblasen haben ist noch dort
oben und China stößte noch nicht so
lange CO2 aus und die Entwicklungsländer
fangen jetzt erst an das heißt wir haben
eine historische Verantwortung da müssen
wir uns natürlich gerecht werden und
dann müssen wir uns auch mal den pro
Kopf ausstoßen angucken jeder von uns
entlässt im statistischen Mittel etwas
Tonnen CO2 pro Jahr 8 Tonnen in denen
die sind gerade mal zwei Tonnen ich mein
Weg und das Recht mehr CO2 auszustoßen
als jemand in Indien oder in einem
anderen Entwicklungsland und insofern
gibt das wirklich sehr sehr gute Gründe
warum Länder wie Deutschland also die
alten Industrienationen hier wirklich
vorangehen müssen
schauen wir uns noch mal die
Auswirkungen an auf dem
Extremwetterkongress hieß es heute auch
dass man dieses 1,5 Grad Ziel im Prinzip
sowieso vergessen kann das sein verloren
und dass man sich eigentlich eher auf
eine drei Grad Welt
vorbereiten sollte wie würde diese
aussehen welche Auswirkungen hätte das
noch mal ganz konkret
eine drei Grad Welt wäre glaube ich
nicht mehr händelbar natürlich geht die
Welt dann nicht unter aber wir hatten
extreme Wettersituationen an die man
sich gar nicht mehr anpassen kann wir
sehen es doch jetzt schon es gibt zum
Beispiel Regenfälle an die kann man sich
gar nicht mehr anpassen das heißt also
es gibt Grenzen Anpassungsfähigkeit ich
sehe das auch gar nicht jetzt so
pessimistisch ich glaube tatsächlich wir
können das Hauptziel von Paris noch
unter zwei Grad zu bleiben durchaus
schaffen und äh das heißt aber
tatsächlich dass die Welt jetzt begreift
was die Stunde geschlagen hat und
gemeinsam versuchte den Klimawandel zu
begrenzen und eine drei Grad Welt würde
wirklich bedeuten dass wir noch mal
stärkere Niederschläge bekommen als wie
wir sie jetzt gerade hatten in Südeuropa
beispielsweise oder Indien die haben ja
auch die Niederschläge sogar in den
Schatten gestellt die wir während der
Art hat so 2021 werden also das kann man
sich gar nicht vorstellen was für
Wassermassen darunter kommen innerhalb
kurzer Zeit so viel Regen wie bei uns im
ganzen Jahr fällt also da kann man
nichts gegen machen ich denke auch an
die Temperaturen bei uns in Deutschland
ist die Temperatur also die höchste
Temperatur die jemals gemessen worden
ist und 2019 war das
41,2 Grad
wärmer dann sind wir da deutlich über 40
Grad in anderen Weltregionen
überschreiten wir dann die 50 Grad ja da
kann man sich nicht mehr dran anpassen
dann würden einige Weltregion
tatsächlich unbewohnbar werden und und
deswegen finde ich sollten wir immer
versuchen unter diesen zwei Grad zu
bleiben und es ist noch möglich das
zeigen alle Simulation die wir
durchgeführt haben und wir dürfen nicht
nachlassen und deswegen finde ich eben
auch diese klimaklagen so gut und das
deutsche Bundesverfassungsgericht hat es
ja auch noch mal deutlich gemacht worum
es geht es geht letzten Endes um die
Einschränkung der Freiheit der jungen
Menschen ja wenn die nicht mehr
vernünftig auf dem Planeten leben können
haben sie letztendlich auch keine
Freiheit mehr und ich hoffe dass
tatsächlich der Europäische Gerichtshof
für Menschenrechte das auch erkennt und
die Justiz muss endlich über ihren
Schatten springen und nicht immer in
Formalitäten sich ergehen und sagen ja
wir sind nicht zuständig oder die Frage
wird abgewiesen wegen eines Formfehlers
das geht nicht mehr und ich glaube
deswegen kommt der Justiz im Moment eine
ganz ganz entscheidende Rolle dazu also
viele viele gute und wichtige Gründe
dass Ruder doch noch irgendwie
rumzureißen dazu schreibt auf Facebook
Hoffnung dass diese Jugendlichen sich
für eine bessere Umwelt engagieren
relativ ich danke Ihnen sehr für das
Gespräch und wünsche Ihnen noch einen
schönen Abend tschüss
danke schön und damit möchten wir uns
auch von euch verabschieden werden ein
paar Tonprobleme heute Abend das tut uns
total leid schauen wir uns genau an wir
danken euch fürs zuschauen für eure
Fragen und Kommentare macht's gut
tschüss